I met this I'm the object that I'm going
to introduce to you today I'm Betts long
after left school
even after I graduated from UT and did a
mathematics degree still didn't know
that this thing existed and then I found
out about it and my brain just shattered
into a million pieces and I kind of
think because I know a lot of you for a
significant number of you despite the
fact that this is the class it is a
significant number if you will never do
maths again after this classes over um
at least at least in a formal sense and
so I do it as an immense tragedy that
are you never get to meet this but it
takes some work to get there which is
why you're not special dog because it's
outside the scope of the course it's
outside the scope of any interesting
force
so it's built upon an idea that we sort
of meet it extension to but I want all
of you to know so this lesson kind of
has three apps the first app is we're
going to look at it very very just the
bed details which everyone can hear of
the idea and extension to which is your
fun okay then we're gonna build a second
idea which is not even in extension - so
that'll be new ground for everyone and
then the third act is I'm gonna show you
okay now
I should also point out this is often
called the most beautiful formula in
this one reason why I'm so keen to show
to you in all of that like because this
is what methods with you yeah
unlike BuzzFeed there's like top 10 top
10 fight scenes in Marvel movies or top
10 you know keeping or whatever right so
people people always this is like innate
human desire to conquer my part in this
right now on top 10 lists for
mathematical formulas this one without
exception universally is always at the
top every time but I kind of think the
word formula is a bit of a misnomer when
I think of formula it's kind of like
he's a set of steps you do to get
something out the other end I think
there's a formula for the area of a
circle right
or if you put this in you get this out
okay this is not a formula it's an
identity it's a relationship between
things that form two sides of an
equation okay so if you have already
make this heading and then just get
ready to change my okay because we're
going to throw some difficult places but
I promise it will be worth it like I
said my intention is for everyone in
this room regardless of how much math up
in your class to use to understand this
okay so I'm gonna go right back to the
beginning okay all mathematics in every
culture throughout history no matter
where you are geographically it always
starts with the same idea which is
counting right even very very young
children have this this concept of
counting so it's fairly sort of
fundamental to the way we work and the
way we so understanding interpreting
reality around okay so you start with
counting but as soon as you have
developed counting it's fairly intuitive
to move on from there to addition right
like addition is actually it begins just
kind of as an extension of counting
right you plus one plus one plus one and
then you're like well why can't I add
bigger numbers than that right so we
could write something like oh another 11
plus 6 equals 17 so addition comes out
naturally and then as soon as you have
addition you have subtraction right so
you can put things into a pile and you
can take them away and that's what
subtraction is right so we can write
something like fire take away 3 equals 2
now despite how how little of a distance
we have gone in terms of like
mathematical concepts okay
counting an addition are incredibly free
things there are no rules really for
counting and is you can count anything
you like in fact that's all the most
things the most amazing things about
counting that you know little kids when
they're like what's the biggest um you
can think of oh okay in your life brandy
you can keep on blowing up people's
minds there's no rules to do with what
you can can't count and so same with
addition right but the second you hit
subtract
this is the first moment with suddenly
you will give something to a child and
they'll say or you can't do that right
for instance you can't do this right if
you give this to a young enough trial
you say what's three take away five
they'll say you can't do that that's
their response right think it's not that
crazy you know it's been a long time
since you've got that but why can't you
do three take away five yeah there are
only three objects there you know three
object it I have I know what five take
away three means it means you have five
things and then you take away three of
them so that's what you get left with
all right but if you reverse it you're
like well I've got three things and then
I take away one then I take away to the
Tegra 3 and there are no more things to
take away okay so when they say you
can't do that what we really mean is I
can't imagine a number that would be a
meaningful sensible answer to this
question right I don't have that number
in my head and then eventually we learn
actually you can imagine a whole family
of numbers a whole category of numbers
that's the answer to a question like
this right how we call them negative
numbers I'm saying okay well if you
include these with the other ones we
call them integers etc okay now all the
way through as we progress through
mathematical concepts we encounter
problems like this right so this kind of
problem right
I might phrase it slightly differently
I'm a phrase in terms of like an
equation you have to solve okay so if I
said to you X plus 3 equals 0 I tried
tell me the number that you add 3 to it
you get 0 okay try to solve this
equation sort of necessitates okay I
need something called negative numbers
right and I don't want you to UM I don't
you to miss negative numbers we're a
crazy idea for centuries people are like
what you can't measure them all right
it's like this table can be missed by
this but you can't say it's negative
this or I can't have negative cows or
whatever right it doesn't make sense in
a counting scheme but this isn't the
only time that this kind of thing is
that we've had to imagine a new way of
thinking about numbers because of a kind
of problem we've tried to solve for
instance he's another one if you went to
an ancient Greek right they would have
said well you can't do that you can't do
that because there's no number they
could imagine that would be a suitable
solution to this equation right they
would think to a fraction still would
they but blue in the Flay face and no
fracture will do it but no fraction will
do it and so they said well if there are
no numbers that are rational that a
ratio between two things we need to
imagine a new family a new category of
numbers and we call them irrational
numbers now I should say just like with
negative numbers that these numbers were
considered just nonsensical for
centuries right and that is why the word
irrational literally in our language
means nonsensical when you say stop
being irrational right it's it's a whole
number for the time when this idea of
like we know this means not ratio you
can't write as a ratio right um
the square root of five okay it's a Serb
you have a hope with a whole new
category of things right but because
there's such a crazy idea this word
which means not a ratio came to mean it
doesn't make sense now this has happens
many more times but at the time I'm most
interested in for an equation is this
guy okay you get a connectives you can
have irrational numbers but no negative
numbers no irrational numbers will solve
this equation we don't we can't imagine
this concepts right of what kind of
number would be a suitable meaningful
equation to this right and I've been
dropping the word imagine on purpose
because the category of numbers that we
actually invented are called
the imaginary numbers again I'm getting
sick of hearing this probably this is a
derogatory term right which was
fashioned by the people who opposed the
idea of this and they said these numbers
aren't real where are they in nature
where can you find these at least I can
talk about these as like you know
backwards and forwards or I can think
about these on like on the hypotenuse of
a right angle triangle where you define
these huh go
go look with them and tell me where they
are they're not real and so they were
called imaginary numbers because you
can't measure them you can't see them
all that kind of thing now this
particular equation is important because
kind of like that building block at all
of this if I gave you X square plus 3 X
plus 5 or X square plus anything all of
them would be a version of this one just
bigger or smaller okay if we went ahead
and solve this let's get this down with
me you should have all three of these
really if I take this X 1 plus 1 right
so we'll just do the normal thing that
you would do when you're solving
equations like this use all your
algebraic manipulation skills you'd say
well I want the X's on they're running
so get all the constants out of the way
you know well I guess I take the square
root of both sides there all right and
this is the point which we say oh you
can't do that right you nine and ten and
even tune extension one who says you
can't do that but what if you could
right so we call this guy we say that
the square root of negative one we give
this a name we call it after the name
right
we call it fine okay I'm every square
root of a negative number
okay the square root of negative 5 right
or the square root of negative 16 they
just multiples of I right you get that
like for example if I set the square
root of negative 16 we can use so mum we
can use some operations here to separate
this out this is root 16 times or
anything you want you agree right so
that's 4 times the square root of
negative 1 so that's 4i okay so this is
just kind of like your basic building
block you don't need new names for all
of these guys if they're all just bigger
in smaller versions of the square root
of 81 okay all right so this idea of you
can't do that well what if you could
okay now we call these guys imaginary
numbers if you put them together when
the numbers you're already familiar with
these negative numbers rational numbers
etc they're actually kind of like oil
and water but they don't quite mixed
together they stay as the real part like
these guys over here and then there's
this imaginary part which it's almost
like our where it's like well they're
not like terms so you can't just put
them together right but you can still
work with them to get
right even though like say two x plus
three wines and seven right this is a
standard by movement we've looked at
before now these are X's and Y's they're
not gonna mix together but they can
still interact when you go ahead and do
the binomial expansion as long as you
keep them in there separate sort of
compartments but it's still one binomial
does that make sense so if you put
together an imaginary number with a
normal number and you feed off the all
numbers we call them conflict though
because like what's it's it's more
complicated there's more facets to it
than all the please have simple numbers
here so probably worth writing down if
you take an imagine above and then you
add it to a real knob on these are all
the numbers that you've been dealing
with before these guys then we call that
a complex number okay